our first is a way to prevent
lovely begin the hunt and torch the path
behind you when vos falls the entire
galaxy will beg to serve me Star Wars
The Old Republic is reaching its fifth
year anniversary and to kick off this
celebration
their newest expansion nice of the
eternal throne not only brings new story
elements but new modes too which begs
the question is there enough in this
expansion to make you want to return to
a galaxy far far away join us as we
explore some of the new elements this
expansion has to offer
story-wise you continue your journey as
the Outlander trying to bring an end or
take control of the eternal Empire
fighting a new foe named Valen the
daughter of the Emperor who invades your
very spirit she's on a killing rampage
hunt down the remaining members of her
family talk about family trauma at the
end of the day I was allowed to play
through the entire first chapter of the
single-player campaign the gameplay
although adding in some new abilities
for each character class it was a nice
change of pace actually jump into a
vehicle this time around for starters
you can now pilot your own Walker into
battle raining down hill fire on your
foes with a variety of weapons it wasn't
a dramatic change of pace for me but it
was nice to get off the ground and get
into a vehicle for once and to rate
havoc on my phone when I was outnumbered
all in all it's a nice add-on to some
gameplay tweaks that this game
desperately needed
chapter 1 of the single-player campaign
kept me wanting to come back for more
after I finished it and even though I
got a chance to make only one choice at
the end of chapter 1 which can heavily
dictate which side of the story you
follow this definitely warrants
replayability next time aim to kill show
off to new modes have also been added
into the mix starting with their biggest
entry galactic command once you beat the
single-player story you are given the
chance to rule your own empire with your
friends choose the dark side or light
side and fight to control key areas on
the Galactic scale the more areas you
conquer the more powerful your faction
grows and once you conquer certain areas
special NPC controlled bosses will spawn
to defend your territory from enemy
players
in Inferno mode which is a tie-in to the
new uprising mode you and three other
players storm a volcano base taking down
two Sith Lords and their elite followers
the purpose of Inferno mode is to give
you co-op challenges to complete with
your friends this mode was fun at times
but in really in all honesty it didn't
feel all that different from the past
raids in the previous expansions new
levels and new characters is always a
treat but we're gonna have to wait and
see what the other maps have to showcase
in this new mode at the other day I had
a fun time with this expansion I didn't
get blown away by the new modes but the
single-player campaign kept me invested
in wanting more it's really gonna depend
on what you're looking for if you're
looking for a new take on the
single-player campaign and I think this
expansion might be right up your alley
if you're looking for new modes to play
with your friends they do offer that
here but it's not a drastic change from
what's already been previously released
what do you think of the new expansion
before you leave your comments below
when we'll see you guys next time right
here on GameSpot Mandalorians help the
Alliance make our cellphone bhaskar
their victory sequels a new force on the
battlefield the Outlander
a vessel holding your father's spirit my
entire family on Voss oh we are going to
have so much fun